Welcome back I hope that you
were able to rest a little bit
after this long sequence.
What we did in the first part of
this lecture
is take the description,
the informal description of the
expression
problem, sorry not the expression problem
but the countdown problem.
The expression problem is something
completely different, you can Google that
and
again you can spend years trying to
solve the expression problem.
But we are trying to solve the countdown
problem here
and what we did is we constructed
a brute-force solution where
we just generate all possible
expressions
and then checked whether they satisfied
the rules of the game. What we're going
to do
now is we're going to try to check
if we can avoid to generate
invalid expressions up front.
Our hope is that this rule
definitely gives a performance
improvement because
there's only quite a small fraction
of all the possible expressions that are
valid.
The way we're going to do that is
we're going to look at
pairs of expressions and their
values. This is the expression
and this is the value, so we carry around
both the symbolic representation of the
expression
and the numeric representation of the
expression.
And what we want, is we want to have a
function that fuses together
the generation and the evaluation
of the expressions. This is the
result evaluating the expression and
that is the
result of generating the expression but
we needed
the result of evaluating the expression
to check
whether it satisfied the constraints
of the game.
That's what we're going to do, we're
going to try
to define a function that will combine
the generation and evaluation.
The way we can do that is as follows:
if we want to find the results
for the empty list well that's the empty
list, when we want to
generate the combination of expressions
and their values
for a singleton list, well what do we do?
We did what we did before we
generate the expression, we know its value,
but this is only valid remember when
the number was greater than 0
so now we can put this test right here
and the rest of the code is now
fairly obvious where we just do exactly
the same
except that we recursively call results.
And then
we still have to define the combine
function here
that will do the same thing that will check
whether the result are valid. Here is
combine, it's exactly the same
as our previous combine function, except
that now we also check whether the
results are valid.
You see that we can do that because we
are now
carrying around a pair of the expression
and its value
and that allows us to check here whether
the result is valid as we are generating
these new expressions. It's a
small
change but it's
quite dramatic. Here's the new
function that solves the countdown problem
and it's just using
this new results function here so we
take all the choices
we calculate the results given these
and then
we check whether the result is the one
that we want. In this case if we run
this now
it's about ten times faster so it's now
four hundredths of a second
and also this guy here, which used to be 43 seconds,
is now down to 3.5 seconds.
This is fabulous, this is really fabulous
Can we do even better?
Can we do even better? And we can.
Because we have now eliminated
generating invalid expressions
because we were generating the
expressions with their results such that
we could always check
whether they were okay. But they're still
cemeteries that we're not using.
Because if we have x times y
thats basically the same,
or basically, that is the same
as y times x. We don't have to
generate
both of these two results.
If we happened to multiply number by one
we might as well just use x.
If we use these properties we will
eliminate,
we won't be using the
expressions here on the left
because they are considered to be the
same
as the expressions on the right.
Hopefully
we can reduce the search space
for this. That's what we'll do
in the next part. Take a small break
and I'll see you soon.